Big Ben is tilting to the north and
keeps leaning about a millimeter a year
the 58-story Millennium Tower in San
Francisco has sunk over a foot since it
opened in 2009 according to a lawsuit
and the former construction manager for
this 57-story 77 million dollar building
in Manhattan said it's leaning about
three inches its developer says it's
structurally stable still the building
sits unfinished the Millennium tower has
undergone a 100 million dollar
construction project to fix the
unanticipated movement according to its
owner
these issues all have one main cause the
ground
so to build taller buildings on
imperfect soil developers are using an
old technology for a new purpose it's
called Deep soil mixing I think it has
been a game changer completely Game
Changer but there are risks here's how
it works
the incredible weight of skyscrapers
requires a strong Foundation to stand on
in Miami Andres pakoriso is helping to
build the city's first super tall
Skyscraper the Waldorf Astoria Hotel and
Residences Miami on ground that looks
like this layers of porous Limestone and
sand not ideal for a 100 Story Tower so
bakurizo and the team are literally
changing the Earth using deep soil
mixing at the end what you end up doing
is improving the capacity of the soil to
withstand better loads and support
buildings or different conditions to do
this workers bring in high torque or
really powerful drill rig this big blade
carves out wells in the ground that can
be up to 110 feet deep here they'll be
around 40. imagine your kitchen blender
but in this case it's a 9 to 10 foot
diameter blender this blender has some
blades are going around the ground and
is shooting cement through those blades
then cement mixes with the soil to form
super strong slurry called soil creep
giving the soil a higher load capacity
so what you'd end up taking is a soil
that we only have a certain amount of
capacity and your increased compression
capacity the lateral capacity on it and
you're going to make it really stiff
making it stiff and almost impermeable
these Wells are arranged in an
overlapping grid so that all of the soil
is properly mixed every one of these
cells right that little circle there
that seems little is really between 9 to
10 foot diameter it also makes the
ground almost impervious to water with
at Waterside properties like the Waldorf
Astoria means you don't have to fight
the tide before when you were having the
dewatering bean run is a race against
the water to when you can do the work if
you're going to have a high tide low
tide deep soil mixing can also help
buildings withstand natural disasters
like earthquakes and the Hurricanes seen
in Miami when wind can cause problems
for super tall buildings what happens
typically with winds is that it will
push the building to try to tilt and
when it's tilting it's literally push
the building sideways but more
importantly in the foundation if you
realize if it's going this way one side
is pushing and the other one is lifting
so now you have a tension condition and
a compression condition if you increase
the capacity of the of the piles to not
be bent laterally and increase the
compression capacity and a little bit of
the tension is going to end up helping
the building to be more stable deep soil
mixing's ground hardening abilities not
only make a building like this possible
they make it more profitable for example
developers have been able to add more
High floor condos than they would have
if the building was shorter they'll
start at 10 million dollars each and
will look like these renderings more
people are willing to say you know what
it's interesting let's go for it so
you're beginning to see this increase of
the size of the city and the height of
the buildings the construction company
building the Waldorf Astoria Tower is
now using deep soil mixing for shorter
residential projects across the country
and around the world they've used it
here here and here to prevent soil
shifting under skyscrapers and that's
just one company's projects other
companies also have projects underway
across the globe but the method comes
with some risks so if a building was
demolished to be able to put a new
building and they left anything made by
man the big blender is coming into the
ground and shooting cement will hit this
obstruction and may shift out of
location or damage the tool if you get
shipped out of location and you don't
realize that it happened then during the
excavation process you wound up getting
some water intrusion that's when water
flows into the excavation a small amount
is normal but any flow larger than a
garden hose can be hard to fix take a
nearby Miami project una residences as
an example in March 2022 water entered
the unfinished Foundation during deep
soil mixing creating what looked like a
lagoon and concerning residents
the developer said that construction is
back underway
and some land like beach sand is just
too soft for deep soil mixing if the
technique is used on soil that's not
quite right the layer of soil Crete can
crack when it begins to break the
difficult thing is in most cases you
almost have to start from scratch
because if you already found you have a
weakness it's not something you can
reinforce as you are as a water will
always wants to come in Pre deep soil
mixing was
sites like oil refineries where the land
needed to hold heavy equipment
Miami was the first city where at some
point the industry realized that this
condition could help us improve the
capacity of the onsite soils and from
Miami that has been developing is now
beginning to go into other places of the
world but due to the unique engineering
challenges that Miami's sandy soil
presents andres's team of Engineers are
paying close attention to the
construction the progress the team makes
here will help inform the company's
Engineers around the globe on how to
make more stable ground for their
buildings as we use it more we have been
able to understand better the system to
keep using their benefits into the
benefit of the buildings so for me has
been a game changer
[Music]
thank you